when we think of an anime fight we often
think of giant swords or
out-of-this-world weaponry with magical
powers if not then maybe mecha battles
are the next to pop in your mind with
some of the most memorable fights in
anime history involving those as for the
swords or weaponry statement I think a
lot of attack on Titan fights feature
extensive scenes of eye catching
sequences thanks to the maneuver gear
and the scale of the battle however for
this video we're not talking about those
this week I'm gonna be spending time
briefing you about the next best thing
hand-to-hand combat I said the next best
thing but that doesn't mean that these
fights really plays second fiddle to
seeing leave I slice up the Beast
tighten or Gilgamesh unleashing the gate
of Babylon on some poor soul in some
ways hand-to-hand combat sometimes feels
even more intense and important than
those featuring swords and weapons after
all here you have characters getting
down and dirty outright using their
bodies magically enhanced or otherwise
to deliver a world of hurt to their
opponents without further ado let's get
to it
we start off with a bang by taking a
look at Aaron's fight against the female
Titan now which fight are we talking
about here
Aaron and the female Titan had numerous
scuffles in the first season of attack
on Titan but we're gonna be talking
about the first one seeing the death of
the Levi's squad Aaron goes into full
rage mode as he always did
seriously Aaron and rage mode seems
synonymous with each other transforming
himself into a Titan hope seems to be on
the way for the good guys and the female
Titan would be put down by our heroes
empowered state well not really this is
attack on Titan we're talking about here
and we just saw teamwork crumble in the
face of an insurmountable foe still Eren
gives it his all in this epic battle of
the B Hamas that remain one of the most
memorable moments of attack on Titans
first season the two Giants traded and
matched up to each other with
earth-shattering blows but at length
it's the female Titan who comes out on
top pulling Eren out of its flesh and
blood mecha in style it's a nice fight
that firmly cemented the female Titan
status as a major threat
those who recognize kiss shop more as
the little vampire Shinobu will probably
be surprised to see this side of her
because it won a guard to these
highlight 5 features her better with
araragi and it's as graphic as it gets
an omnipotent being looking to die kiss
shot looks to fulfill that goal by
fighting araragi the problem is that
being a powerful being that she is the
fights not gonna be so easy the only
thing that keeps the duo alive is their
own powers and regeneration in the end
kiss shot arguably lost this one on
purpose yet one can't deny that she had
one hell of a fight normally now I would
say something like that's how you make
an emotional climax of an arc but the
fights so cartoony in its delivery and
animation that it probably appeals more
to a certain demographic still kudos to
the animation team for showing us this
epic battle the anime changed some of
the things so you might want to see the
novel version of this fight it offers a
slightly different yet fulfilling new
experience
seeing a poster of the psycho-pass anime
would make anyone think that this anime
is not going to be one to feature a lot
of notable hand-to-hand combat began
Auto Buchi masterpiece having a premise
backed by psychological themes revolving
around mortality does tend to lean
towards more shootouts and cerebral
battles
you probably remember the series more
for its themes and charismatic
characters however it's also here that I
unexpectedly saw one of the best
hand-to-hand fights in recent memory
kogami vs. makishima as a fight on
psycho passes episode 16 is an intense
slugfest the two combatants contrasting
personalities reflected in their
fighting styles and it's just a lot of
motion the two slug it out pitting
makishima's Grace and precision against
the rough street fighter in kogami the
fight features minutes of crisp
animation and it spills all over the
place it was a hyped fight back then and
looking back at it now it's certainly
aged well
a hand-to-hand combat videos not
complete without a rep from legendary
boxing anime Hajime no Ippo to make way
for the next fight on the list
Sawamura versus if ball I'm not sure
about you guys but for me Sulmona is
probably one of the toughest opponents
if bo had to face in the entire run of
the Hajime no Ippo anime this fights
also in my opinion the culmination of
Sawamura arc and looking at the fighting
context makes it even better throughout
its run Hajime no Ippo has spoiled us
with gritty intense fights and this
one's no exception given that if ba is
fighting the greatest counter punch of
all and a psychopathic individual at
that this fights in no way of walk in
the park for a hero the long fight
presents some of the best twists and
moments in any it ball fight in the
series and you really have to see it to
believe it
in some ways Hajime no Ippo is really
one of the kings of hand-to-hand combat
when you talk about anime the fight is
also notable for the Dempsey roll scene
so you might want to take note of that
as well
for all the praise the fete series has
gotten for its animation and soundtrack
one entry that often gets overlooked is
Apocrypha most people know Apocrypha for
Mordred Jean and a Stahl fo but it also
gave us one of the best hand-to-hand
battle scenes in the franchise given how
the franchise prides itself on
historical figures and their
otherworldly noble phantasms you'd be
surprised to see a straight-up
hand-to-hand battle like this but it did
happen
the battle between Achilles and cheerin
is a fight to remember two fighters in
their decisive battle gave us one of the
best sequences in fate Apocrypha with
each impactful blow the viewers get
sucked into a very immersive and
visually impressive fight their final
fights the well-deserved payoff for
Achilles journey in overcoming his
personal obstacle remain a beer you for
table show the fate Apocrypha is an
often overlooked gem that deserves more
love
[Music]
hand-to-hand fight sounds like a job for
Saitama with how easy every fight is for
Saitama it's really a bit hard to
pinpoint a fight that's drawn-out and
contains a lot of epic moments however
Saitama taking on the onslaught of an
entire race is something that will live
on for the near future looking at the
animation for this fight you'd be
surprised to see what peak one punch man
was like especially if you just came
from watching an episode of season two
the animation the camera angles the
close-ups it's all there such an
exhilarating fight gets pushed to
another level thanks to the work they
put into the animation well I'd like to
speak much more on the fight itself now
but what can you say would you expect
that with Saitama it's not really a
fight we can comment much about because
it's practically a slaughter but it
turns out the Saitama was just dreaming
up the entire epic encounter the fight
was wonderfully animated it has some
really great hand-to-hand action if you
want to see a whole race go extinct in
the span of a few minutes by facing off
against one Baldy you've got it in this
fight here over the years one piece has
given us a lot of cool and emotional
fights in addition to the emotional
context and the weight of the fight I'd
say that the battle against Lucchese one
of Luffy's fights that is all about his
raw power for a lot of fights luffy
receives help in true Shonen fashion
whether it be surviving crocodiles
initial assaults through luck or law
helping out against doflamingo and
others however this battle against
Lucchese a good old physical brother
barring some motivations from a sob
basically is a battle that luffy won
through effort not a lot of plot related
device is going on around to help Luffy
secure the win and were treated to a
nice little slugfest that features the
two combatants answering each other with
blazingly hard punches and physical
feats
cool
I've recently talked about gone versus
Hisoka in another video I think that
what carries this fight really hard is
the context and how it plays out in the
grander scheme of things in Hunter
hunter for so long her soap has been
this obstacle that urges gone forward in
addition to his previous goals after a
scuffle that ended poorly for our
protagonist the two go head-to-head once
more in the heavens arena go on taste
the initiative and starts the battle
with his preemptive strike what follows
is a touch-and-go fight where both
fighters calculate each other's moves
the potential that's been teased forever
foregone is in full display and the two
fighters go at it in some good old
unarmed combat when the dust clears his
soca remains standing tall victorious
over his plucky opponent there's no
shame in defeat for gone though as
despite him looking out matched he
surely gave his soak a far tougher fight
than the Enigma would have imagined
heading into the battle
[Music]
looks like deja vu here doesn't it the
spike in Vincent's fight is once again
second place on another list one of the
greatest fights in the 2000s makes it
back and barely misses the top spot once
again however that's not enough against
the fight as far as the fight is
concerned it's a glorious work of art
especially considering the context you
wouldn't expect animation like this in
the 2000s and what it shows simply blow
some of the modern anime fight scenes
after the water spike in Vincent's
battle features action that's intense
fast crisp and chaotic the to fight all
over the place and it's not every day
that you can get a fight where you feel
every ounce of emotion from the
combatants backed by really excellent
delivery in each blow it's rare to see
an uphill underdog battle beat this epic
remember this moment if you've been
following this channel for a while of
course you'll remember this moment
nevertheless Obito versus Kakashi is
here once again and we have to partly
thank the Builder for that builders
ninjas at the top of their game as well
as having an entire mini arc dedicated
their past Kakashi and obito have all
the makings of a big-time match their
inevitable confrontation and conclusion
of their year-long storyline has been
hyped to hand them back and when we do
see it it delivers in every possible way
despite me talking about the build-up
that's not to say that the fight is in
any way shabby the blitzing speed at
which this fight happens in sidecar
movie and the responding of powers
between the two tip-top fighters all
come together to create one of the best
fights in Naruto's decade-long history
period
and that's it for this top ten list I
wonder which one among these fights is
your favorite I want to know your
thoughts so please let them be known
through the comments section below
as usual if you enjoy this video and
want more content like this the like and
subscribe buttons are there and make
sure to click the bell button - that way
you'll be immediately informed whenever
we release a new video I hope to see you
in the next video there's a lot more to
come so I'll see you next time on Vinnie
tube
[Music]